[Música]
llega el momento de hablar de economía
aquí en France 24 Buenos días Daniela
para usted y buen viernes Hola Buenos
días María Clara un placer estar acá
Bueno le propongo que hagamos una
combinación de temas y es tecnología con
economía porque la Inteligencia
artificial sin duda está haciendo la
noticia del momento y tesla utiliza esa
Inteligencia artificial para los
vehículos que se manejan solos sin
embargo hay una noticia y va a mandar a
revisar a miles de sus vehículos no Así
es María Clara miren En total son
362.758 de estos vehículos de lujo que
serán retirados del mercado para
solucionar un problema que tienen con el
Software que permite que se conduzcan
solos Esto está denominado el full self
driving de beta y pues la administración
nacional de seguridad de el tráfico en
las carreteras de Estados Unidos dijo
que ese software podría por ejemplo
hacer que se excedan los límites de
velocidad o que inclusive los coches
viajen a través de intersecciones sin
cumplir con las normas de tránsito y al
final eso en qué desemboca Pues que
podría causar accidentes algo que la
misma empresa reconoció en documentos
enviados a esta autoridad los
comentarios de los usuarios no se
hicieron esperar escuchemos
Acabo de recibir la noticia no sabía
nada de esto para ser honesto y lo uso
todo el tiempo utilizo mucho la
conducción Autónoma principalmente las
autopistas y no he tenido ningún
problema
no había oído hablar de eso pero
obviamente cuando estás innovando ahora
altibajos y volverás a la tienda para
tratar de mejorar las cosas
y Esa no es la única noticia en Estados
Unidos Daniela porque pidieron cárcel
contra el fundador de la firma de
criptomonedas ftx Por qué pues mire él
se llama
de apenas 30 años menor que nosotros
inclusive María Clara y está en Libertad
bajo una fianza de 250 millones de
dólares a la espera de un juicio
programado para octubre el que una vez
fue conocido como un ejemplar
emprendedor de la industria de las
criptomonedas es señalado de estafar a
inversionistas por miles de millones de
dólares y desviar estos depósitos para
financiar donaciones políticas y también
para realizar transacciones muy
riesgosas en otra de sus empresas Hoy
está confinado con monitoreo electrónico
en la casa de sus padres en California
pero pero un juez cree que debería estar
en la cárcel esto porque está abusando
del uso del internet Bueno dos cosas ahí
Daniela Sam claramente es más joven que
nosotros usted ahí reveló nuestra edad y
también reveló nuestro presupuesto
porque claramente es más rico que
nosotros dos juntas es mucho más rico
que toda esta sala de redacción junta
podríamos decirlo bueno y cuéntanos cuál
es el principal argumento que está
arguyendo el juez para pedir la prisión
Pues mira qué interesante Ellos dicen
que podría estarlo utilizando el
internet para tener comunicaciones no
rastreables por ejemplo para tratar de
influir sobre los Testigos del caso Pero
lo que más temor les da es que pueda
cometer inclusive delitos porque
reconocen que él es una persona
tecnológicamente sofisticada yo diría
mucho más que eso es casi un genio de
las criptomonedas la sospecha es tal que
inclusive sacaron a colación que accedió
a un sitio de internet encriptado para
ver el partido del Super Bowl Aunque el
juez se burló de él dijo que esto estaba
en cualquier televisor increíble bueno Y
usted qué piensa de que un genio no solo
de las criptomonedas como usted lo dice
sino de la tecnología en general tenga
acceso a internet estando un poco
recluido Claro que sí lo que dicen
inclusive los jueces y los fiscales Es
que él no debería tener ningún acceso a
la comunicación y lo que él dice y sus
abogados es que si no tiene acceso a
internet pues no puede prepararse para
el juicio que va a hacer en Octubre y
bueno debería existir cárcel para muchas
personas también que usamos tanto
internet Bueno y ahora cambiemos de tema
porque la duma rusa pidió formalmente
investigar sabotajes contra el gasoducto
nord Stream pues mire la cámara baja del
parlamento adoptó un proyecto de
llamamiento a Naciones Unidas en el que
propone Iniciar una investigación sobre
las tres explosiones submarinas que hubo
el año pasado en esta que era la el
Principal medio de transporte de gas
ruso a Europa not streaming tiene un par
de tuberías de gas natural en altamar
que se extienden bajo el mar Báltico
desde Rusia hasta Alemania y sufrió una
serie de voladuras de las que el kremlin
acusa a occidente como actos terroristas
por eso pide llevar ante la justicia a
los perpetradores de lo que llamó un
crimen injustificado que puso en peligro
la seguridad de todo el continente
euroasiático esto ocurre días después de
que el periodista estadounidense simure
señalará en un informe al ejército de
este país y a sus Cómplices noruegos de
haber cometido este ataque entre tanto
también se conoció que Estados Unidos y
sus Aliados del grupo de los siete
planean presentar un nuevo gran paquete
de sanciones contra Rusia desde el 24 de
febrero esto cuando se cumple
precisamente un año de guerra Daniela
Cuál es la cifra de este viernes 1400
millones de euros en ayudas que
inyectará el gobierno francés Air France
que es la aerolínea en la que posee un
30% de participación los recursos buscan
compensar el impacto sufrido por la
pandemia y representan también el tercer
paquete después de dos anteriores que se
habían otorgado por once mil millones de
euros el dato muy curioso es que el año
pasado la aerolínea casi que duplicó sus
ingresos a más de 26 mil millones de
euros increíble entonces esa inyección
de tanto dinero con estos claro no va a
ser muy bien recibida ahora precisamente
que Francia está en estos complicado
momento político Daniela gracias por
toda la información económica